me gustaría que tuviéramos la
oportunidad entonces un poco
entonces si pudieran mandar la mano a
todos aquellos que vio al colegio a la
universidad donde en el último anuncio
perfecto
vamos si pudiera levantar la mano
todos aquellos que durante este proceso
educativo llegaron a ser judía
conocieron al mítico
es difícil de admitir pero una bebé
hacia dicha es de ambas desde muy
pequeñas nos enseñará la cerca
se cargan las sillas es importante que
les contemos un poquito sobre el maestro
padre
la verdad sea dicha es que estuvo los
inicios muy buenos
sin saber que mañana desde niño se
levantaban las 4 de la mañana
el campo para subir
y la educación era un privilegio que
solamente pudo llegar hasta el colegio
pero pese a estas limitaciones tan
grandes después de muchos muchos años de
trabajo no era junto con sus hermanos
construir una de las compañías más
grandes económica que hoy en día
conocemos como arrúa y arrastrándola
de transferencia de mundos de
permitiendo analizar lo que significaba
educación para una persona ya decía que
quienes recibía medicación tenía la
oportunidad de ir a más
en pocas palabras este tramo y esté acá
y amazon a estudiar algo como el
rendimiento de negocios es efectivamente
hacen trampas de acuerdo a la
universidad que avisora aquellos que
estudian emprendimiento de negocios
llega a haber más de 5
[Música]
las personas que no estudian
no sólo es los graduados del
emprendimiento de negocios tienen a
través del 65%
y es así como a través de la vida de
nuestro padre nos dejamos de hacer
trampa con la educación especialmente a
la hora de empresas no teníamos que
exponer la universidad teníamos muy
claro que queríamos ir a la mejor
universidad del mundo al emprendimiento
a negocios que nos enseñaran de una
forma práctica y además de eso
tuviéramos acceso a las mejores
herramientas que existieran para ser una
compañía
en casa tuve la oportunidad de ver una
metodología más la paz que inclusive
pagada todavía la utilizo cada vez que
voy a hacer una empresa y herramientas
recuerdo una increíble que era como un
videojuego que tengo poniendo
situaciones de una compañía y
defendiendo
pasaba al siguiente nivel con títulos
es así como nuestros 20 años no teníamos
nuestra compañía nueva york
la madre reconocida por el mar saben de
miranda comunidades tecnologías haciendo
madurar de frente
lluvia hemos recaudado de 2 millones de
dólares y habíamos logrado lo que menos
le había tomado toda una vida
pero de preguntar millón sigue siendo la
misma quien puede pagar por hacer drama
mutación una buena
muchas personas porque como todos
sabemos la educación cada vez es más
costosa e inclusive que en los últimos
20 años ha incrementado en un 300 por
ciento y cuando sea también en
comparación con otras industrias la
educación siempre está normal los
primeros puestos incremento de cosas
y si a esto le añadimos que sólo 228
universidades en el mundo de carreras
la mayoría de estas universidades
[Música]
que menos de 1.000 por ciento de nuestra
población
a
y está la nación en la que nos
encontramos estoy aquí llevamos cinco
años trabajando
sin importar su profesión geográfica o
económica tenga la oportunidad de ser
trauma con la educación con la mejor
evaluación del rendimiento a negocios
que existe
pero llegar a realizar la educación y
emprendimiento de negocios se necesita
mucho más
es por eso que a través de mi
experiencia que se especializó en
entender un a través de medios digitales
que podría llegar
a una población como la florida
la misma prisa que aprendió escriba de
los retos más importantes no son tan
ricos como los pensaban sino que son
retos culturales
como sabemos las personas en países
desarrollados utilizando la tecnología
de una manera muy diferente a como lo
hacemos las personas en los países
y canadá
es un medio
todo lo que es educación informal y si
realizamos las 10 palabras más buscadas
en colombia
encontramos que 8 de esta escala
tienen que ver con música con baile de
vídeo me empezamos a la mañana
en dos palabras
ninguna tiene que ver ni con educación
ni con tecnología
entonces estamos viendo aquí realmente
que hay un tema algún problema que
estamos que si hacemos un ejercicio con
ustedes levanten la mano los que tienen
acceso al computador e internet
[Música]
muy bien
y así también para acceder a las
plataformas de revertir en haití que
está bien español y además están
traducidas pero están traducidas en
español
100% gráficas
muy pocos
muy pocos que las esto sigue siendo un
problema pero el tema
portugal es muy importante
definitivamente nosotros utilizamos la
tecnología de manera diferente la
educación una manera seria
con una gran diferencia entre lo que el
computador puede llegar a hacer y lo que
la sociedad desea ser por eso es por eso
que crea megamente contenido de no
iba a ser suficiente para educar a la
población latinoamericana
para el organismo teníamos que colombia
este programa es así que nace mañana un
programa educativo que le enseñó a casa
para los emprendedores cómo hacer su
empresa con las mejores metodologías del
mundo pero que hemos reclutado a muchos
emprendedores de la región
esta canción se podría llenar la vida en
colombia
adicionalmente el medio era muy
importante y decidimos ir dos nutrias
que son listas normalmente compuestas el
entretenimiento y la educación el canal
y medio que utilizamos para instalar y
empezamos a comprimir estos en tanto que
en vídeos de lo que suben los lunes
y el alcance ha sido increíble que sólo
hemos tenido un crecimiento de 600 por
ciento y a través de nuestra alianza con
la revista dinero cuando hicimos el
deporte con los diez pasos para ver el
resultado encontramos en dos de nuestros
días artículos ofrecía a dos de los
artículos más leídos en esta revista
ahora el alcance humano solamente es
porque personas emprendedores de todo el
país no se estaban contactando haciendo
preguntas de emprendimiento del meta de
nariño de choco inclusive la semana
pasada una niña en una que viven en
tennessee eeuu entonces esto quiero
los colombianos
simplemente lo hacemos de una manera
a través de también logramos
democratizar la educación y ponerlo en
la mano
pero como bien lo digo de verdad
el emprendedor cuánto ha merecido a
través de cintra mexía necesitan
muchísimas herramientas no sólo la
educación así que en el momento de
pensar cuál sería la herramienta y nuria
a desarrollar en poner en manos de los
emprendedores colombianos empezamos a
ver y analizar cuáles son los factores
que más inciden en el emprendimiento
[Música]
y no se sabía pero la nación número
mundo por lo que los colombianos estamos
fracasando a la hora de empresas
establecerán con temas financieros
lo interesante es que cuando hablamos
los inversionistas ellos nos dicen que
desearían que los emprendedores fueran
más profesionales que antes o las
valoraciones de las compañías fueran más
adecuadas que cuando los emprendedores
nos contactaron fuera el inversionista
correcto en el momento correcto
por lo menos un poco difícil de
responder y de pensar porque frente a
los yo habiendo estudiado emprendimiento
de negocios lo más probable es fuera
sentido con tierra de estos hermanos una
valoración correcta saber a qué nación
está llegando en qué momento estamos
hablando de los conocimientos
probablemente un contador un financista
de casi nada así que me he convenido que
yo me enfrenté al reto de levantar
financiación finalmente recurrir a la
persona que más en plana tenía
efectivamente ocurrió
es portadora
de las instituciones financieras más
grandes del mundo
entonces
esta extraña y emprendedora contadora
financista en otras palabras es el
perfecto autor que cualquiera de donde
se hiciera un invento de levanta
financiación así que cuando nos
enfrentamos a la tremenda de que la vida
deberíamos desarrollar a los
emprendedores de nuestro país la
respuesta fácil
debíamos desarrollar a una mano de un
sitio
es muy sincera pesos entran indicador
financiero que desarrollamos
es como tener un contador un financiero
un economista de citi
no hay mejor no
que cabrera tras estudiar
tú puedes hacer tu planificación a más
de eso que enfrentará al inversionista y
sostener porque tus números son lo que
son y lo mejor de todo es 100% gráfico
los rays contestes después de tener en
planificación financiera y tú mismo
pasado de descargar el directorio y want
indica todas las instituciones
financieras que dan dinero a los
emprendedores y las clasifica
dependiendo en qué invierten como a
priori hable brillitos que vivir hacia
el emprendedor puede tener su nación a
comer y walker y abre la puerta a cada
una de estas instituciones
y los resultados han sido increíbles
antes de pesos
uno de cada diez emprendedores tenía un
conocimiento financiero lo más favores
ya tenía algo contamina finanzas
con el día 4 de cada día sean vendedores
durante enero una planificación
financiera aunque hay muchas
herramientas
y educación médica
y rendimiento
a asegurar que sin importar qué
industria de trabajo
hay herramientas que pueden están
utilizando
me toca demasiado
pero además la mente que me ha gustado
es la de la nación
a todos los emprendedores que tenemos la
oportunidad de intervenir y así llegar
al fracaso empresarial
empezamos en colombia
recuerde que el analfabeta del futuro no
serán las personas que no pueden
porque yo a muchas personas
era la persona que no sepa cómo aprender
[Aplausos]